good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to Barnes & Noble Upper West
Side
Joshua green is a senior national
correspondent for Bloomberg Businessweek
focusing on political coverage for the
magazine and Bloomberg News previously
he was a senior editor of the Atlantic
he is also written for The New Yorker
Esquire Rolling Stone and other
publications he brings us tonight his
new book devil's bargain
Steve Bannon Donald Trump in the
storming of the presidency which the New
York Times calls deeply reported and
compulsively readable as of this
upcoming week it is a number one New
York Times bestseller so without further
ado please join me in welcoming Joshua
thank you so much I'm always amazed that
with all the Donald Trump and Steve
Bannon that we're all subjected to in
our daily lives that people want to come
out and get more of it in person but but
I'm gratified so I'm gonna I've been
advised that people at non-fiction book
readings don't really want to hear the
author read is nonfiction books so I'm
gonna read a couple of short scenes and
move ahead through the question and
answer period because people tend to
have lots of questions about Steve Annan
and Donald Trump and so I'm gonna read
two short scenes from the book they've
been very carefully chosen because I
figured out about a month ago when the
first galley arrived and my precocious
ten-year-old daughter wanted to read it
that that this wasn't a book that that a
that kids could read or be that would be
easy to to read at a public reading
because Trump and Bannon are the two
most profane men I've ever met in my
life and even though my daughter's not
allowed to read the book she did figure
out that the very first word of the
first chapter of the book is the worst
word you can say the f-word and so I'm
gonna skip ahead and I'm gonna read two
scenes one is from the night that Steve
Bannon was hired to run the Trump
campaign and the other is a scene from
right at the end of the book after James
commis letter has come out in the
closing days the campaign when Clinton
and her staff wake up to the realization
that she might be in real trouble so let
me let me let me set the scene a little
bit here in in mid August of 2013
everybody in my profession and pretty
much everybody in politics I think
expected Donald Trump to head to a
blowout loss he had just come off this
very dark Republican convention he was
doing OK in the polls for a few days and
then he decided to start fighting with
megyn kelly again fighting with Fox News
he attacked the Khan family the parents
the slain US soldier and everyday Trump
seemed angry and distracted by some new
and different self generated scandal
would seem to be losing about I think
eight to ten points in most of the
national polls and the big chalk on the
campaign trail and in Washington is when
the Republican National Committee would
pull the plug on Trump take away all the
money they were they were they were
backing him with and redirected to try
and save what were thought to be
floundering House and Senate members who
are being weighed down by this terrible
anchor at the top of the Republican
ticket in in the second week of August
one of bannon's or van ins main patron a
woman named Rebecca Mercer who is the
daughter of a conservative billionaire
named Robert Mercer who's as a secret
hedge fund magnate and funds a lot of
conservative causes and also funded
Donald Trump's campaign to the tune of
millions of dollars Mercer was so
frustrated with a way that Trump was
performing that she got on her
helicopter and she flew out to East
Hampton's to a Trump fundraiser and she
sits Trump down and tells him you are
headed toward a defeat unless you make a
change right now and I know just who you
should hire you should hire Steve Bannon
to be your campaign manager you should
bring in Kellyanne Conway as your
pollster and you should bring in David
bossy who is a veteran Republican
operative all three of them had worked
for Mercer and some of her outfits for a
very long time she knew them well and so
Trump agrees but in classic Trump
fashion he doesn't tell anybody else so
we pick up the story on the night of
August 13th when Mercer has brokered
this new campaign team and Trump calls
Bannon up on the phone so let me let me
pick up the scene here that night August
13th Trump and Bannon spoke by phone and
agreed to a deal Bannon would take over
the campaign forgoing a salary as Paul
Manafort had and Conway would be named
campaign manager bossy would later
join is her deputy Trump told Bannon to
meet him the next morning at his Golf
Club in Bedminster New Jersey the next
day a Sunday
Trump's top advisors gathered at trump
National Golf Club in Bedminster unaware
of the leadership change that had been
instituted the night before or of their
bosses foul mood at the table where
chris christie rudy guiliani
roger ailes who is now advising trump
Paul Manafort and his deputy Rick gates
Jared and Ivanka were not there they
were yachting in the Croatia in Croatia
with David Geffen Trump who had been
stewing over a recent Times article
about chaos in his campaign exploded at
mana Ford quote how can anybody allow an
article that says your campaign is all
effed up Trump demanded to know I'm
gonna self-censor here that's not that's
not precisely what Trump said it was a
little more graphic trumped a minute uno
furious at his portrayal and it reports
his aides were going on television an
effort to reach him you think you got to
go and talk you think you gotta go on TV
to talk to me he shouted you treat me
like a baby
am i a baby to you I sit here like a
little baby and watch TV and you talk to
me
am I an effing baby Paul the room fell
silent man afford took the hazing in
stride it was hardly the first time
Trump had lost his temper and while he'd
been demoted he hadn't been fired
besides he had a bigger problem to worry
about after the meeting mana Ford headed
home to his Trump Tower condominium on
his desk was a printout of an article
set to run in the next morning's New
York Times it explained how a Ukrainian
government anti-corruption team had
discovered a secret handwritten ledger
listening man afford as the designated
recipient of twelve point seven million
dollars and previously undisclosed cash
payments from a pro-russian political
party aligned with former President
Viktor Yanukovych mana forts client
although Times reporters had been
pressing him for weeks to comment Manta
forts attorney had advised him against
it now
Ford was having doubts you kept the news
the impending story from the Trump
campaign he'd even kept it from his wife
who lept up from the couch in a fury
when she found out that night by late
Thursday trumpet had enough and demanded
mana Ford scalp although he didn't do it
personally quote it's like the French
Revolution said Roger stone a longtime
Trump advisor the guys who were cutting
people's heads off at the beginning
wound up getting their own heads cut off
at the end
that is how Bannon took over the
campaign I think most people at a
reading like this will have been
familiar were the kinds of things that
Bannon did and said and encouraged Trump
to do and say during the campaign so I
won't rehash crooked Hillary and all the
dark conspiracies that Bannon wove but
one of the things I try and do is give
the perspective of how the campaign
unfolded from inside the campaign itself
from Trump Tower and I got minutes get a
lot of leaked memos and documents and
polling and that sort of thing try and
give a contemporaneous view of what the
Trump folks we're seeing and I have a
scene toward the end of the book this is
after James Comey has unexpectedly
announced that he's reopening the
investigation in the Hillary Clinton's
email server sending the whole campaign
at both parties in the chaos and this is
a couple days later and Trump had a team
of data scientists holed up in San
Antonio Florida some of whom worked for
Rebecca Mercer who were trying to track
the effect and they had very
sophisticated instruments that are sort
of like political Richter scales and you
could see state-by-state what was
happening to Trump's support so here we
are about five days out from election
day throughout the general election both
campaigns battled for a group of voters
who would ultimately decide the race
well media outlets fixated on distinct
character types considered
representative of the election the
dispossessed factory worker re
registering to vote for Trump
the elderly woman longing to see a
female president the real competition
between the
Paine's was for voters of a less vivid
hue Trump's data analysis gave them a
nickname double haters these were people
who disliked both candidates but
traditionally showed up at the polls to
vote they were a sizable block three to
five percent of the 15 million voters
across 17 battleground states the Trump
staff believed were persuadable early on
many indicated support for the
third-party candidate Gary Johnson but
after a series of televised flubs
including Johnson's admission that he
didn't know what aleppo was I know all
you know that Aleppo is a city in the
middle of the Syrian civil war after
after his flubs his Aleppo flub the
double haters largely abandoned Johnson
what made the double hater so vexing to
Trump's analysts was that their
intentions were difficult to discern
many refused to answer pollsters
questions or declared themselves
undecided
the Clinton campaign thought of these
persuadable voters as being mainly what
they called pocketbook Republicans
people whose votes were driven by
kitchen-table economic concerns but were
made deeply uncomfortable by trump's
racist and sexist outbursts these were
the voters that Clinton had hoped to
shear off from Trump with her speech
condemning the alt-right and Steve
Bannon in August quote what we found out
is that they were very fickle one of
Clinton's chief strategist told me they
toggle between telling pollsters that
they were leaning Clinton or leaning
trump depending on where the news cycle
was that week this is the largest piece
of fallout we ascribe to the Comey
letter and ending the campaign on a note
where people were reminded of our very
worst controversies we saw those fickle
Republican leaning voters we've been
successfully attracting on and off
throughout the general election revert
back to Trump at the end for all their
differences on this subject the
campaign's generally agreed this was the
decisive block of swing voters commis
letter had the effect of convincing the
double haters to finally choose an
affiliation
or in the case of many who have been
leaning toward Hillary Clinton choose to
stay home one of trumps data scientists
told me quote what we saw is that it
gave them a reason to vote against her
instead of voting for him they were
finally able to admit that to pollsters
without feeling any guilt all of those
double haters in last-minute undecideds
started to break heavily toward Trump in
the polling and research when deep down
they were probably in a vote for him
anyway
now they had a reason and there was
nothing that Clinton could do to stop
them so I will stop there and open it up
to questions I don't know if we have
somebody with a microphone or if you
just want to stand up and I gotta make
oh there's the microphone so we'll start
over here so please yeah just just quick
questions so I can get through everybody
I'm happy to take political speeches
later on when ohan work yeah my question
is about banning himself does did he
does he have political chops in other
words in his past up until this point is
he the kind of guy that could go into a
room with real politicians and do what
Trump can and really make deals based
upon the entire governmental scene
ruling being a government
now what Bannen has is a kind of a
personal charisma that you don't get
from the public portrayal he he he
cultivates as a kind of a Darth Vader
Machiavellian figure but he comes out of
the world of 1980s investment bang you
worked at Goldman Sachs he is almost a
caricature of like an 80s Wall Street
banker type talks a mile a minute
vaguely sexist very smart very funny but
all they're very alpha male and while I
was surprised that he was named to run
Trump's campaign when I thought about it
made a lot of sense the two of them
would connect if you are a Wellesley
grad like my mom here in the front row
Steve Bennett is not not your cup of tea
but if you are a a steak eating New York
City real estate developer and want to
be alpha male like
Trump that's exactly the kind of guy you
would connect with that's the power that
Bannon has it's not political I think
it's more personal next question here I
was fascinated by the Research Institute
that Bannon and I think the Mercer's put
together and funded two researcher
Hillary as a possible model for a
Research Institute to investigate Trump
and the Trump family how much money was
put into that how did they organize that
how do you how did they talk about
setting this thing up let me back up a
step so I credit I say in the book in
Trump of course hate this that without
Stephen and Donald Trump will not be
President and I make that contention for
two reasons one Bannon is really the
avatar this kind of populist nationalism
the Trump ran on and that resonated so
deeply with millions of voters who in
previous elections hadn't been
interested or active it hadn't hadn't
turned down that's that's way number one
the other way that Bannon helped Trump
when the election wasn't initially
intended to help Donald Trump
specifically rather it was meant to tear
down Hillary Clinton bent what drew me
to ban and originally was he had what
struck me is a very astute analysis of
why conservatives had failed to stop
Bill Clinton in the 1990s and Bannon
argues that conservatives had become so
convinced of their own righteousness and
so whipped up in a fury against Bill
Clinton that they became trapped in a
kind of bubble that they were all
talking to each other and didn't realize
that they weren't bringing along people
in the mainstream Democrats other
politicians and were surprised when you
know they lost seats in the 98 midterm
elections and Newt Gingrich was ousted a
speaker Bannon thought the reason that
happened is because they sorry bit so
that Saban's solution to this problem
was to find a way to essentially hack
the mainstream media
and get this message out of the
conservative fear into broader public
awareness in the way he did that was by
trying to find a set of facts that would
impune clinton rather than the crazy
loopy conspiracy theories the tenet of
circulate in the 1990s so what he did
with backing from the mercer's is he
established already helped to establish
a non-profit research institute down in
Tallahassee Florida called the
Government Accountability Institute
which has I went down and visited a
couple years ago they have teams of
lawyers and forensic investigators and
PR people and what they did is for about
two years they went out and amassed all
the information they could about
Clinton's entanglements or donations
she'd gotten often through the Clinton
Foundation from foreign donors of
dubious character and intent and they
took all this information and they put
it into what became a surprise
best-selling book called Clinton cash by
a guy named Peter Schweitzer a
conservative scholar and investigators
the president of GA I the book was time
to come out right on the eve of Hillary
Clinton's announcement for president but
because it contained facts that were
documental by investigative reporters at
mainstream media outlets these stories
penetrated in a way that the stories in
the 1990s had not and what Bannen did
that was so interesting to me was he
took this information and he went to
investigative reporters in the New York
Times and said listen here's what we
found but don't take my word for it I'm
gonna hand you the book and the
information you go off yourself and
decide if this is something worth
reporting on and about a week before the
book came out the New York Times ran a
front page above the fold story about a
uranium magnate who had donated millions
and millions of dollars to the Clinton
Foundation and Bill Clinton had traveled
over to Kazakhstan to help introduce him
to the autocratic president and it
seemed to suggest some dark nefarious
scandal in the fact that it was
published on the front page in the New
York time meant that
all the other publications we're gonna
pick it up it was gonna get talked about
on cable news and by doing this he was
able to essentially spread these
negative stories about Clinton in a way
that would resonate with mainstream
voters and with Democrats who might
become disillusioned and either not show
up or support somebody like Bernie
Sanders good job Josh what do you think
Joey Gandhi meant when two days before
the Comey letter on a fox interview he
said we have a couple of things up our
sleeve that may change the outcome
and why was Hillary's very good RINO
speech buried after one day and in the
press the RINO species you mean the all
right
speech sure I don't know exactly what
Giuliani was referring to because the
tough thing with Trump's advisers in the
campaign is that you know in a
professional campaign and Marco Rubio
Jeb Bush campaign you would have these
seasoned operatives that would make very
clear to reporters like me on background
okay we're gonna give a big speech on
foreign policy here is the important
here's what we're gonna say here's how
you should think about it they do a
little framing with the Trump guys they
would just kind of fire off at random
and maybe they knew what they were
talking about and maybe they were just
issuing empty threats and I don't think
anybody ever really knew what Giuliani
was talking about and Giuliani is a
little you know a little a little little
unstable to begin with the the other
part of the question
Clinton's advisors when Steve ban and
took over the campaign in in August
thought that this represented an
opportunity for them to steal away what
the Trump campaign called the double
haters people who were probably
Republican but made deeply and
comfortable not only by the racism and
sexism but the beating of protesters and
the anti-semitic imagery that was kind
of flying around the internet and seem
to be associated with Trump so they
decided to give a big speech about it if
said a rooster
it's Bannon trying to sow chaos and ruin
and ruin my book reading so they they
decided to give a speech about it
attacking Bannon and Breitbart news
where he was chairman frontally and the
Clinton came had a big debate do we put
do we put this term alt right in the
title of the speech because most people
had never heard of the alt right in the
end they just and I tell this story in
the book in the end they decided yes
let's do this because reporters are
gonna freak out and readers are gonna
want to know what is this alt right and
it will generate a series of stories
that were affected reflect very
negatively on the Trump campaign so
Clinton went out she gave this speech -
crying Steve Bannon and the forces of
hatred and division and racism and I
sentiment I semitism and it did get
about two days worth of coverage as
she'd hoped but with Trump in the
campaign he could always do something
that would step on a negative story and
so all you had to do was send a tweet or
attack megyn kelly and the media was on
to something else the other problem in
that speech I mentioned I got some of
the internal polling from the Trump
campaign is while I got a lot of
political attention it didn't seem to
hurt Trump with voters Bannon tells me
at one point I think I quote this in the
book he says I'm pretty sure there's a
direct quote he says dude we've pulled
all that stuff it doesn't matter that
the people who were offended by charges
of racism are already on her team she's
not bringing over any new voters and I
suspect that was right so in the book
which I'm about halfway through
you mentioned this internet army that
the redditors and the meemers and so
forth that Bannon became aware of when
he was in the video gaming industry and
what I would like to end his got may
find a lot of press in general and I
wonder if you have a sense of how
important they were they really were in
terms of votes one and graceless of
states want me and also if you have in a
sense of how important Trump thinks they
were great question so the all right
didn't really exist in most people's
awareness certainly not mine you know a
year and a half ago two years ago but I
tell the story in the basically what the
all right there's no greed upon
definition of what it is but now
especially after Clinton speech she kind
of crystallized it as being these armies
of online trolls who would attack anyone
including politicians and journalists
who didn't support Donald Trump and
would say all sorts of racist things and
send anti-semitic imagery it's the sort
of thing that is like catnip to cable
news so it got a lot of coverage I tell
the story in the book of how Ben and
help draw those forces into our
political system and it's a weird story
Bannon was a goldman sachs banker he
went out to Hollywood he became a
filmmaker but in 2006-2007 he wound up
is the CEO of a video game company in
Hong Kong that didn't actually make
video games it was trying to monetize
something known as gold farming I don't
know how many you guys here are gamers I
am NOT myself so this is all news to me
what what gold farming is is that he's
massive they're called massive
multiplayer online games anybody heard
of world of warcraft these are the games
that you know million people can link up
to and you know millennial kids will sit
there for days weeks at a time absorbed
in these things and what gold farming is
you can win gold and armor and special
weapons that will help you advance
through the story gold farming is the
process of winning that stuff and then
selling it to gamers in the real world
and Bannon and his company would hire
teams of low-wage Chinese workers to
play these games and 24 hour shifts win
office called
an armored and sell it in the real world
and it was a viable it was a viable
business goldman sachs invested in this
in this business and it worked great for
about a year until something happened
all of these gamers who weren't cheating
and buying their magic pixie armor
became very upset by the fact that other
people could cheat and do this these
gamers tended to congregate on message
boards the bandhans company actually
owned and they organized themselves and
he went after the video game companies
and said you need to stop this or we're
gonna destroy your business or quit the
video game companies listened they ban
gold farming bannon's business went
bankrupt but the lesson he took away
from
was that there are these legions of kind
of rootless angry white men who went
motivated to do so can be a very
powerful force online so when you took
over Breitbart news five years later he
conspired to bring them over into the
political world by hiring as Breitbart
tech editor a guy named Milo innopolis
who has since become notorious as as boy
I don't even know how to describe him
conservative provocateur is the
euphemism but a guy who goes around
basically offending everyone Under the
Sun intentionally to get attention in it
succeeded Milo brought a lot of these
people over to Breitbart they became
turned on to Donald Trump and these
these masses of online people became
very prominent the election to answer
your question which is great one the the
skepticism I've always had about the
alt-right in the media infatuated with
it I cannot identify a race or a county
or a state where the alt-right vote was
decisive or meaningful in every way in
any way so it's hard to say how powerful
a force they are they were certainly
powerful in the sense that they shaped
the media narrative around the campaign
that they that they amplified this image
of negativity and boundary crossing and
in transgressive 'no stat you know we
never seen in a candidate before Donald
Trump and I think Trump himself was very
aware of this I know Steve Bannon was
and at various points in the campaign
Trump would he claimed accidentally
retweet anti-semitic images images of
Pepe the Frog who was the racist mascot
of the alt-right it gets very weird if
you don't if you if you're not familiar
with this stuff but that's my best stab
at answering the question Thanks Bannen
made Trump Ken Ben and save Trump I'm
not I'm not sure I'd agree that Bannon
made trouble I think Trump made Trump
Trump was Trump before ban and ever came
along I think what Bannon did was to
kind of amplify and heighten Trump in a
political context he gave ballast
to Trump's populist impulses which well
I don't think they were rooted in any
authentic interest in policy
we're nonetheless evident as long ago as
1988 when he used to go on Larry King
Live and pretend he was running for
president and talk about how we were
being swindled and ripped off by foreign
competitors many of the same things that
he says today what Bannen did was to
bring structure to those beliefs and to
bring a media movement and also as we
talked about with GA I this this
interlocking group of conservative
organizations that could get behind
Trump's candidacy and that proved to be
very effective both in Republican
primary and in the general election
whether or not he can save Trump I don't
know my inclination is to say no Trump
is so self-destructive so unwilling to
listen to any advisor that he doesn't
want to listen to there was a there was
a a belief in the media or a way of
portraying ban and early in the
administration the idea that he was this
puppet master and this great manipulator
Saturday Night Live had the wonderful
president ban and skits where the Grim
Reaper comes out and makes president
Trump sitting a little boys desk I don't
think it was ever quite true and it
enraged Trump who through you know CASP
in and out of his inner circle he seems
to have crawled back somewhat but Trump
isn't really capable of focusing on
anything for very long I mean I'm sure
that Bannon is frustrated that he's got
the president he wants he's chief White
House strategist Republicans have
unified control of Congress and yet they
seem unable to get anything done at all
and the one guy in the administration
who is getting something done for Trump
his attorney general Jeff Sessions who
is cracking down and deporting
immigrants just as Trump claims he wants
and as I know ban really does want looks
like he's about to be fired or driven
out by his own presidents I don't think
Ben I don't think Ben can save him
I am I'm wondering what is it about the
Republican Party that allows it to be as
receptive to the sort of alright which i
think is white supremacy this white
supremacist wing of the Republican Party
and if are there forces within the
Republican Party that can sort of that
are sort of prepared to or eventually
we'll be able to fight back against this
and make it as sort of that's a great
i I think let me answer that question in
two ways first of all until Trump came
along and until Ben and Breitbart became
really prominent in the political
conversation around 2013-2014 probably
when Congress pushed to reform
immigration laws there was almost
universal sentiment among Republican
leaders that the Republican Party needed
to modernize and needed to broaden its
appeal not only to Hispanics but to
African American and young people and
gay people because all of those groups
were growing as a share of the
electorate and you didn't have to be a
genius to look ahead a couple years and
realize oh boy they're all Democrats
they're part of the pie is growing our
part of the plot pi the elderly white
rural working-class folks or not are
actually shrinking and so there was a
big push to try and modernize the
culminate the sad culmination of that
effort was Reince Priebus --is what was
called a autopsy Priebus was the
chairman of the republican national
committee when mitt romney lost
unexpectedly to many republicans he
commissioned this far-ranging study
about how the GOP could broaden its
appeal it's it's its main conclusion was
that they needed to pass comprehensive
immigration reform which of course they
didn't Jeff Sessions and Steve Antin
helped stop that and it was Trump who
recognized the power of illegal
immigration to motivate these Republican
voters and exploited that to win the
nomination than the presidency there are
principled conservatives in the party
who are aghast at this and many of them
have very bravely come out and said so
they're called
never Trump errs I I think I think the
hurtful realization a lot of them have
had is that they they thought before
Trump came along that they had real sway
and influence among the Republican
voters places like National Review which
ran an entire issue devoted to why
Donald explaining why Donald Trump was
unacceptable
they were universally ignored by
Republican Party voters and I think the
reason that the elected Republicans have
been so willing to go along with this is
that they're frightened of their own
coalition they they most of them will
tell you or will tell me off the record
that they don't agree with what Trump is
doing they think it's ugly and terrible
and bad for the country but they're also
frightened because these are the people
that vote in Republican primaries and so
Trump and ban and have have have
awakened them to the power of this
resentment and and in how stoking
anxieties over race or religion can
easily be exploited and wielded as a
weapon especially in a Republican
primary and so what you wind up with is
what we see in Washington right now
these these kind of cowed and crave and
Republican elected officials who just
don't seem willing to stand up to Trump
hi even though your book your work
concentrates on on the influence of
Stephen Bannen and Mercer's with with
your research and also with your if your
own personal opinion did you find any
research that specifies any involvement
with the Russians and do you personally
feel that their Russians had any sway
and election results because you know
all these polls that are we're
predicting this Clinton you know the
comfortable victory at the last minute
and this large upset is you feel it's
completely Bannon and all these things
Elaine in the book or I guess it was
anything with the Russian I I don't
think Ben it wasn't involved with the
Russian
so far as I know it never came up in the
six years I spent kind of embedded with
him reporting with him while he was at
Breitbart he was very interested in
Clinton email story and I know he and
all sorts of other conservatives we're
really hoping that they would come out
GA I the Research Institute had very
sophisticated tools to to comb through
the Deep Web it's called which are sort
of the parts of the internet that Google
can't reach and that are sometimes
repositories and information that you
can't get otherwise I know he wanted
them but I'm not aware of any contact
yet with the Russians and the reason I
think he's so far been done he not been
implicated in the Russia scandal is that
it seems like Steve Bannon has been in
our lives forever but in fact he only
joined the campaign in August which was
two months after the controversial
meetings between the Russians and Don
jr. and Jared Kushner so he literally
physically wasn't present for those
meetings so I'm not aware of any any
Russian connections but I certainly
accept the conclusion of intelligence
officials that Russians intentionally
meddled in the election and might have
had a decisive effect on the outcome
what do you feel is the connection with
Benin and the fake news not the fake
news of Trump's version I got you the
real kind of fake news can you his real
fake news the thing I know it I know
it's talking about so before Trump
bastardized the term fake news used to
refer to stories that were literally
exactly literally fabricate it and there
were BuzzFeed has done wonderful
reporting to show that there are teams
of like teenagers in Macedonia that
would produce these entirely fictitious
fabricated stories send them rocketing
around Facebook people would read them
think they were real they often looked
very real it was almost a form of
psychological warfare Bannon never did
anything like that and Breitbart news
gets attacked by the left as being a
propagator of fake
I think them is doing something
different they're very partisan news but
they try and root their news and facts
in actual stories what they tend to do
is put a very hyperbolic headline on
what might otherwise be considered well
I was gonna say a normal news story but
Breitbart you can never you can never
call Breitbart stuff normal what they
what they try and do is spin real news
stories in the direction that they want
put a framework on them that is the way
they would prefer that stories were
understood sometimes those are smart
sometimes those are absurd in the
campaign they were off and obsequious
and and and and super favorable to trump
but so far as I know they didn't
intentionally publish news that they
knew was fake any other questions okay
Mike my question is about the media I
think that Trump is able to bounce the
media like a ball and today like today
he's getting getting the media or track
blessing in transgender and the armed
services so what can the media do to
really talk about real things and not
about what Trump tweets every day that's
a fantastic question and it has been the
it has been the central challenge of my
profession for a year or two and clearly
is gonna be going forward I I'd say a
couple of things first of all I don't
think one of the reasons that Trump was
able to do this and get away with it
during the campaign is that I think on
some fundamental level no one believed
that Trump was actually gonna win so you
you you could you could kind of just
take a deep breath and say to yourself
this is absurd but it's not gonna have
any kind of real impact Trump is gonna
lose the Republican Party will be
anguish and fight this civil war
and meanwhile President Clinton will go
about her merry way and it was only
because of a perfect storm of
circumstances I think the Trump was able
to win one that he wasn't taking that
seriously to than an enormous amount of
of investigative effort in the
mainstream media was directed at Hillary
Clinton but there wasn't nearly as much
directed at Trump but I think the real
reason is the Trump and Bannon to a
lesser extent really is a master of
understanding news and especially Cable
News and how to manipulate it and as you
point out what Trump did today is the
perfect example of that I talked about
one of the one of the interesting and
disturbing scenes in the book that I
talked about that I think also fits into
this is what happened inside the Trump
campaign after the Access Hollywood tape
the Billy Bush one where Trump said
undid awful terrible course things all
the mainstream Republicans abandoned him
it looked like that was the end of the
race and I described a scene in the book
of how Bannon fought back and what he
did and Bannon decided that the problem
was the only story on cable news for
about 72 hours was the Access Hollywood
tape and so you need to change the
imagery well how do you do that well
bannon's answer was you bring out these
Clinton accusers you accuse Bill Clinton
and Hillary Clinton of having committed
and enabled sexual violence and it will
be such a circus in such a display the
cable news cameras will race to cover it
and then all sudden what's on TV is it
Access Hollywood maybe a little bit but
that's not the only story and you've
muddied the waters you've created
controversy and you have a guy like
Trump who then went in during the second
debate and attacked Clinton to her face
for this very thing and then we as the
media are in a difficult position on one
level we know what they're doing trying
to muddy the waters and and and cause
some misdirection on the other hand the
Republican candidate is saying this in a
presidential debate we've got to cover
it so it creates a real problem in
today's news Trump's sudden tweet that
he's banning transgender soldiers from
serving in the military is the classic
example of bannon's
kind of psychological warfare everything
on TV has been Trump attacking Jeff
Sessions that's bannon's a lie he hates
it Trump himself seems unable to control
himself or stop himself so someone got
in his ear and said you know these
these lefties and in there you know
loose social mores can't be permitted to
infringe on the power and might of the
American military why don't you send out
a tweet saying you're not going to stand
for this and that's exactly what Trump
did and sure enough the media comes in
and covers it although my impression is
they did it a little less willingly and
a little less overwhelmingly than you
might have seen say a year ago during
the campaign so I'm hoping that we're
learning our lessons and in the meantime
I would point out that the media has
gotten much much tougher in its coverage
of Trump the coverage of the Justice
Department and Trump's problems with
Russia and lack of tax disclosures and
Bob Muller Special Counsel investigation
every single day that story's being
advanced it's on the front pages of the
paper and you know it's on cable news
because it's driving Trump crazy we we
do we do actually need to do this
binding we have a lot to cover I
understand that but we do have to move
to the signing if there's any final
comments for mr. green before we do move
to the signing questions thank you all
so much for coming out I really
appreciate it it's wonderful to see you
all
[Applause]